Hello everyone and welcome to some human on human action featuring Hikaru, Nakamura versus Magnus Carlsen
It's around 6 of the London chess classic, and it's a pretty big game for Hikaru Nakamura.
So far in classical games and Nakamura had a pretty terrible score against Magnus Carlsen
Of all the games they played a Nakamura won only one game
I think it was the one in 2013 in Bilbao
and lost 12 games to Magnus Carlsen. So the score is 12-1 with 23 draws.
That's a that's not a very good result.
Here, Nakamura has the white pieces and more importantly tomorrow is Nakamura  30th birthday
So this win would definitely mean a lot to him you know
- yeah, um, you know -
for when he wakes up and for his birthday, that he defeated the world champion, and for the standings in the tournament.
So let's see this game
Nakamura has the white pieces and we have e4
So already, seems like it's gonna be an exciting game.
e5, nf3, nc6 and d4
Nakamura goes for the Scotch
And, uh
Probably, probably, inspired by recent AlphaZero games and his games against Garry Kasparov
exd4
Knight captures on d4
Knight to f6
Knight captures on c6, b captures on c6 and, now, e5 : the Schmidt Nice's variation.
We have Queen to e7. Queen to e2 and Knight to d5.
And, here, I believe it was a Kasparov who played this against Wesley So
in the ultimate blitz challenge.
(variation) C4 was played and then there's Bishop to a6.
But in this game
Nakamura goes for the early h4
Preparing a very early rook lift also probably inspired by games of AlphaZero.
Bishop to b7, c4 now, knight to b6 and rook to h3.
Queen to e6 by Carlson
F4, we have castles and a4, now, And I remember there was a game between
Gary Kasparov and Anatoly Karpov. Karpov, I think was playing
I don't know if Karpov was white or black
But either Karpov played h4 and a4 or it was h5 and a5. And Kasparov said :
''This is no way to play chess''
You can't push h5 and a5 or h4 and a4
- doesn't matter-
He went into a deep think and then crush him
But we'll see how Nakamura pulls it off
d5 by Carlsen now a5
Giving Carlsen two options
well three
But I guess na8 isn't something you want to play
since a6 will trap your bishop
but he can go Knight to d7 or he can accept the challenge by playing Knight captures on c4
and Carlsen accepts it he plays nine characters on c4
B3 now the knight has nowhere to go
Bishop to b4 with check we have King to f2
and now
Knight captures on a5 and there was a this
I don't think this was an easy decision for Carlsen if you play something like Bishop back to c5
Then it really depends what Nakamura plays.
If he plays the King do you want you can always repeat moves
but if he, at some, points decides to play King to g3
Then you have this maneuver Bishop to g1 now not allowing the King to escape
through f2 or h2
So probably rook to h1 kicking the bishop back
but now Bishop to d4 with an attack on the rook and
After something like rook to a4 now Queen to g6 check
Checking the King and attacking now the knight that is undefended on b1
You have to react to this and the only move is Queen to g4
Blocking the check and also checking the black King and after the exchange happens now knight to e3 check
king to f2, if you captured than bishop captures, so King to f3
Knight captures on f1, now a6 will, first, kicking the bishop.
Bishop to a8 and now rook captures on d4
But now it seems like your knight is trapped, but actually Carlsen would have a way out
see five would an attack on the rook.
Rook to d1 and now e4
Creating a discovered check from this Bishop on a8
and also creating an outpost on d3
for the night so after King f2
ne3, the knight is able to save itself
Bishop captures, dxe3 ,with check, then  king captures.
It's a pretty. It's a pretty equal endgame
Carlsen would have a nice bishop against the night,
but still
Both rooks are on the board,
both pairs of rooks are on the board, pretty equal.
So, after King to f2,
Carlsen decided to go for the for the feisty variation :
knight captures on a5.
We have bishop to d2 and this is the problem :
you can't capture the bishop.
If not, knight captures,
protecting the b3 pawn, and this knight has nowhere to go
So, after Bishop d2,
c5 was played and now of course this was Nakamura's idea all along
Rook capture knight on a5.
Bishop captures and bishop captures
so two pieces for a rook.
Queen to a5 by Carson he has to control the c2 square if you allow Queen to c2
then this c5 pawn is
Probably gonna fall and moves like Knight to c3 to b5 are coming attacking a7 and c7 the bishop is also attacking c7
So Carson has to defend the C 2 square
Nice to see three now
Queen captures on f4 with check King to g1 nakamora doesn't mind giving up another pawn
we have rook H to e8 and this was a
this was also probably not a very easy decision as
You could go for something like d4 and after d4 Knight b5 attacking c7 and after a six
Knight captures and our rook to d7
Queen to c4 rook captures Bishop captures King captors and Queen captures on c5 with check
King b8 now p d6 check King to a8 and Bishop captures on a6 rocked the c8 now
preparing ideas like rook to c1 check the Queen is covering h2
But then either Bishop captures and this force a draw Bishop to c4. It's a pretty equal game
The material the material is equal
So hard to say probably a draw
So after Kings to g1 cross and plays rook HD EA instead of d4
Knife to b5 now and here we have a six
Rook to f3 first kicking the Queen away
Queen captures on e5 Queen captures rook captures and now Bishop captures on c7
attacking both of Carson's rooks
Rook to e8 now Bishop captures rook captures and Knight back to a3 and at the end of this variation
Cross and is down a piece, but he does have three points for the piece
So can he core do this a piece against three pawns?
We saw that alpha zero can pull off a piece against against four pawns, but that was a bishop pair
So let's see how he card does this against the world champion
rook to d7 Carson defends the f7 pawn
Bishop to d3 now and
Here he's attacking this
H-bond and it's not like in Fischer Spassky that this is a poison point you can trap it with g6 and because h5 will break
Break open the position
Kink the d8 was played and you can also play something like g6 this does preserve your pawn
but then rock to f6
Allowing the roof to infiltrate the position
This this might have even been better than what Carlson played because the rook will infiltrate the position anyway
So after Bishop to d3 Carson played King to d8 starting to activate the King and now Bishop captures on h7
g6 temporarily trapping the bishop and now h5
G captures on h5 and rook to f6 so drop hazard
You know it still came to f6 infiltrated the position and there was a there was some talk of rook to f5
In the commentary like attacking d5 pressuring
I mean attacking h5 pressuring d5 not allowing this point to be pushed because then c5 would be hanging
But nakamora decided to go for rook to f6
Not allowing Carlsen worship to go anywhere Bishop the c6 was pretty much. The only way to develop the bishop
Give it some use, but now it really doesn't have any moves
So King to e7 attacking the rook and now rook to b7
rocked the c7 by Carson night to see to
a5 we have night the e3
C4
Bishop to c2 now Bishop the c6
B captures on c4 big captures on c4 and rook to a6 now going after the a5 pawn a for
Bishop captures a 4 and now Bishop to e4 so
Carson now has 2 points for the piece and there are they're not any connected points
They're just three point islands, so it shouldn't really be a problem you
know Europe Europe a piece three separate Bonin Islands is
Shouldn't be a big deal
rook to a5
King to e6 rook captures on h5 now and c3 so now Carson has only one
extra pawn for the piece, but it's it's a passed pawn and c3
Preparing to be pushed on c2
We have Bishop to b3 check King to d6 Bishop the c2 now not along with the point to be pushed
Bishop captures and c2 Knight captures on c2 and now came to e6 and
How do you win this? It's it's not very simple especially when you're playing the world champion
King - f - now hikaru improves the position of his King f5
So the King can approach deeper into the position the rook was blocking it
rock to h3
We have Tim 3:5
rock to D 3 into F 4 by Carlsen rock to d4 check King goes to g5 now King to f3
rook the c8
Rock to a for rock to c7
rock to a8 and King to f6
replace X check came back to g5 nights to d4 and
Wrote the C for attacking the knight knife to e6 check
King to f6 Knight to f4 a discovered check from the rook
King to e5 and nights to d3 check teens to d5 and look to a 2 now not allowing
the point to be pushed
And king to d4 now attacking the knight
Knight the c1 was played with a c2 by Carlsen and
This is a very critical moment in the game
Here, Nakamura has to play rook to a3 and not allow Carlson's King to approach deeper into the position
But instead of rook to a3 Nakamura played rook to a5 and it seems like it's a perfectly fine move
you know you're winning the f5 pawn and
sooner or later you will sacrifice your night for this C pawn and then simply push the Jeep on out of the board as
The answer calls it the the G Pony Express
Wrote the c3 check King to f4 when a Kimura rook to c8 now and
Again, this was probably
I'm pretty sure this was the last chance, Nakamura had to play rook to a3 to again. Cut the king or
Out of approaching this c2 pawn but instead Nakamura played rope captures an f5 and here
Nakamura was already very low in time, but Carson had like over half an hour on the clock and
he got really excited because I think Carson also I think he got the flu or something she looked pretty sick and
Leonard oats the photographer said that
Cross and looked really sick
But that he couldn't get a good photo of him being sick
So rook to e8 course and finds it and this is the only moves move that gives black a chance
The idea is rook to e1
Attacking the knight and when the knight moves to b3 then rook to be 1 and then the night won't really have anywhere to go
You will be threatening promotion so roof to f7 by Hikaru rook to e1 now as planned route to d7 check
King to d3
King erupted to c7 check King to d2 and now Knight to b3 check
And this is the position Hikaru probably saw when he captured that F pawn
He probably
calculated King to d1 or maybe King to eat too because if you play King to d1
This simply doesn't work
What Hikaru missed was King to D 3? Which is what Carson played?
Because if you play King to d1 then rook to d7 wins easily
But now if you play King to d3 rook to d7 doesn't do anything King to c3 you attack the knight rope to b7
rook to be one now and
You can't really do anything about this you have to push the g4 pawn
rook captures on b3 and after rook to c7 check King to d2
There's there's no way to win. This rook captures c2 King captures. It doesn't really matter and
It's a draw the the pawn will go up the board
so after Kings to d3 here he carved knew that he blew it that he will not have a a
Nice birthday present tomorrow morning when he wakes up
And he played night to c5
Kink the d4 Knight the b3 would check keep the d3 like to c5 repeating again here
He karo had less than a minute on the clock
King to d4 again Knight to b3 check King to d3 and here it was a three-fold repetition
But Carson didn't call the arbiter - you know
- telling me. It's a draw
And here, Nakamura. I mean it was a three-fold repetition, but Nakamura still doesn't want to play
Knight to c5. He wants that victory for his birthday birthday tomorrow and
He plays g4 so everybody was very very I'm not gonna say shocked
But very surprised that he car was still trying to win this
So rope to f1 check King g5 and now rope the b1 as planned
And here you don't really have anything else to do a 95 check again King III
Nice to be 3 now Nakamura is trying to get cost him to grab the night
But if you grab it and rocky afters and c2 and then the Jeep on will win the game now
So after night b3 Carson ignores the night simply King to d3 and I see 5 check King III and after Knight to b3
In this position cousin called the arbiter and said that he's about to make third move that will create a three-fold repetition
so in this position
Carson and Nakamura through the game, so
As of this day the the new result between the two of them is 12 wins Carson 1 win, Nakamura and 24 draws
so
Too bad for Nakamura could could have been a very nice birthday tomorrow, but you know
You're playing the world champion
It's it's never easy so yeah
That's the game I would like to thank all the richness
Andrew Bergman a Benjamin glides man and Peter Mitaka for a contribution to my channel. Thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can check to my previous videos here. I think all for watching and I will see you soon